l'yonne monde s'est excusé et
aujourd'hui on se retrouve sur
borderlands 2 donc qui vient tout juste
de sortir bon aux états unis il sort en
france le vendredi 21 donc c'est à dire
après demain donc j'avais eu à créer un
personnage bon c'est un assassin donc la
classe nay peur et puis y'a remet au
corps à corps avec son sabre j'ai pas
été super content du truc bon dans tous
les cas pas le continue on va créer un
nouveau perso pour la découverte de
bande annonce deux donc c'est développé
par gearbox software pour l'éditeur tout
cas games est le premier du nom était
sorti en octobre 2009 il me semble voilà
allez c'est parti
alors vous voulez une autre histoire
l'histoire où c'est le destin de pandore
qui se joue oui ma part j'espère que oui
parce que je vais l'a raconté dans tous
les cas j'ai très petites annotations
percée qui veulent ce délai ce matin'
d'un tropiques on les guerriers qui sont
parvenus à y entrer l'argent n'a été que
tentacules et déception ils se sont
volatilisés dans les terres désertiques
persuadé que l'arche ne renfermait aucun
trésor
ils avaient tort couverture de l'arche à
déclencher l'apparition des rides y
sommes un élément aliens d'une valeur
inestimable
le précieux minerai s'est vite retrouvée
aux quatre coins de pandore attirant de
nombreux intéressés
dont la société voilà périence est
implanté sur pandore pour exploiter les
rides y sommes et faire la loi sur cette
planète sauvage sous la surface
elle a découvert la trace d'une arche
bien plus importante
son chef s'est mis en tête de la
débusquer afin de sensibiliser les
borderlands une fois pour toutes
cependant hyperion n'était pas la seule
à convoiter la puissance aliens de cette
nouvelle arche
difficile de résister à l'appel du
danger et du butin des foules de
guerriers se sont donc lancés à l'assaut
des secrets de pandore des aventuriers
les siennois déjà conseillère pour d'eau
l'assassin jusqu'à comme c'était les
appels des chasseurs de l'arche notre
histoire débute avec eux avec
très bien alors là on passe à la petite
île o matic d'un trou j'ai vu tout à
l'heure il ya vraiment rien
d'exceptionnel ça met juste en jeu les
personnages que est dur en trois quatre
minutes toute manière on doit déjà être
sur youtube y a pas besoin que vous la
voyez je vous rassure
alors est-ce qu'on fait un commando
assassin non c'est non ce sera plutôt
entre commando commandes aux sirènes ou
solaire je sais pas moi la référence jan
allez hop c'est parti on peut choisir et
tout haut à g pas vu ça dit non au mieux
puisqu'on va prendre pour moi j'aime
bien comme sa tête
ah ah mais ses yeux liboi frissant c'est
horrible bon allez hop c'est parti à
conserver
j'aurais dû appeler ce quiz est zut bon
c'est pas grave alors vous allez voir
que graphiquement gm sont que c'était
retravailler
ça me semble beaucoup plus groupe d'en
fabriquer le plus fin beaucoup plus
agréable que dans 1 est en tout cas le
jeu est très très bien optimisé sur pc
rassurez vous c'est pas comme je me
souviens blackops par exemple qui était
pas très bien où tu faisais stade hier
qu'il fallait un gros pc pour très peu
graphiquement là c'est l'inversé
faut pas forcément un groupe et c'est
tombé
toujours j'étais là le trafic quelque
chose pour tous madden le mois comme
dans leur nom ils descendent et donc non
en fait c'est d'ailleurs un accident ce
qu'on adore les cinématiques donc ils se
retrouvaient là et il s'est retrouvé par
le rouge alors nouvelle clé lors
disponibles jean claude heures pour une
clown au rendez-vous quand lui serre la
ceinture avec platini avait été vue plus
de gens s'intéressent d'accord alors ça
c'est parce que j'ai préservé le jeu
très bien et j'ai aussi une relique
d'accord ok allez c'est parti
celle-là d'or lapa
alors donc elle c'est l'attenté
c'est là alors on fait ça cette femme
qu'on va voir à répétition c'est
l'intelligence artificielle qui se
trouve dans le bidule qui nous a donné
donc en fait c est là un fait qui va
nous guider à travers tout ce monde
fantastique
regardez comme c'est beau le ciel on
voit une autre planète juste la fin
c'est vraiment graphiquement c'est
magnifique moi je peux vous dire je sais
même plus le nom que sa dalle et ça
c'est du cell shading voilà cel-shading
ça s'appelle et honnêtement ça rend
vraiment très bien et ça a été
retravaillée par rapport aux 1 c'est
beaucoup plus fin et est beaucoup mieux
bon par exemple petit petit petit
vignoble à dark funeral qui n'aime pas
du tout le cel-shading pourtant là je te
dis refus que c'est beau mais je pense
avoir enfin bon c'est parti
la preuve les premières doit on se
retrouve donc dans borderlands 2 c'est
vraiment injuste je suis j'y crois pas
trop
les collaborateurs de la région
s'appelle coeur de primates
c'est un gars robot il a pu tout ce que
je connaissais
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que je garde
une arme dans cette armoire en cas
d'urgence
ouf bah le voilà dix dont elle fait peur
ça je peux vous le dire
ce pauvre robot est sombre toujours
plein la gueule dans les vents vers
l'inde alors qu'il n'a rien demandé
l'arrière oui bon salut toi je peux
m'asseoir
ouais mon meilleur pote faisait oui à on
est bien là un trou béant mec trop bu
ils disent tu vois toi qu'est ce tu veux
bon
l'objectif est marqué sur la map est il
faut prendre vraiment up
j'en prends alors attendez on va prendre
on va seulement changer d'air parce que
vu que j'ai précommandé le jeu je
devrais normalement retrouver des armes
en dehors like this
mais voilà ça fait peur jusqu'au bac
allez savoir
graphiquement mais si ce plan dit je
sais pas si vous pourrez bien voir gm au
caire de mettre une petite couleur
corail sean sympathique c'est vraiment
splendide m'étais bien le 720p vous
verrez que c'est waouh c'est bluffant
sincèrement c'est bluffant super sa
sonde voyager pillay d'accord j'ai pas
encore utilisé ce avec mon autre perso
qu'on va appeler mon mail mais il mène
ces tests n'agit pas dans les mémoires
pg bon rpg tout court d'ailleurs
j'ai pas encore utilisé je le demande la
croissance en mai regardez là le petit
effet de la neige sur l'écran vraiment
mais vraiment je le trouve alors
vraiment splendide ferment à ça c'est le
corps à corps de là alors on trouve
aussi des caisses comme ça voilà qu'on
peut ouvrir récupérer ce qu'il ya dedans
elle va envoyer de l'argent ou des
munitions la veille et les munitions
l'occurrence plutôt sympathique tout ça
bon vous verrez qu'au niveau des armes
c'est un peu du grand n'importe quoi des
armes qu'ils ont d'être au top aussi lé
même système que dans tous les rpg en
août des sytèmes de plusieurs couleurs
donc leblanc l'orangé le bleu violet le
rouge fin je sais plus les couleurs de
borderlands soit un bref c'est pareil ça
va du du vert ou violet me semble alors
on a dénoncé par les tuer hélas ceux qui
ne connaissent pas bordeaux nantes voici
la particularité on a des dégâts quand
on tire sur l'ennemi
lorsque ouais parce qu'en fait c'est un
mélange entre le rpg et le fps qui
personnellement un très très bon mélange
bikey qui a conquis après tout ce qu'ils
ont fait du jeu on s'est vraiment part
ça qu'on se paie ton qu'il sait pas par
exemple si vous regardez dans le menu
les armes vous mettez votre souris
dessus vous voyez par exemple assure la
gauche au niveau des dégâts qu'a fait la
précision la cadence de tir etc et les
des gamins quand vous tirez sur les
huiles et des liasses affiches et ça
donne une sensation assez agréable je
dois bien avouer c'est vraiment vraiment
sympathique bonbons le sang est un
petrov une avance assez sympathique
on fait des sauts si le géant mais un
mets donc oui voilà ce petit côté rpg
qui ajoute un peu de
enfin je ne saurais pas trop vous dire
mais qui donne un côté bas on devient
facilement raccroche pour pour ceux qui
deviennent accros enfin qu'ils
ressentent le besoin de jouer au jeu et
bain avec borderlands elle est gâtée
c'est moi qui ai voulu on a trouvé de
l'argent
argent qui sert donc à acheter des
équipements si bien dit c'est un rpg
classique mais sous forme de fps avec un
sécher les prenant enfin vraiment c'est
si ça qui fait la base de beurre
d'amande alors survie dans la tête
justement fin plus critique
voilà comme ça j'aime bien cet humble et
sympathique il efficace
et regardez notre copain hp goudjo voilà
encore il est pas ma tête tout crispé
tient pas brusquement sa vraie
voulez-vous les allées voir que c'est
vraiment un boulet explique moi donc le
beau jake on laisse la pète un peu là
faut bien l'avouer cela pète un petit
peu ce gars il est un peu saoulant bon à
prendre ça on continue alors toujours
cette touche d'humour dans les
borderlands a vraiment qui sont ou
violent le boss avec les deux petites
pattes fédéraux j'adore
or ce qui caractérise un peu bande en
saucisses et toutes les conneries que
ceux justement ce petit claptrap peut
dire il saute dessus attention faire
vraiment attention les vents violents
cela c'est pas un boss pour rien alors
il ya des bosses dans borderlands je me
souviens le boss du dernier dlc devant
l'argentin était vraiment mais il était
simplement et la tête voilà critique il
était immense mais alors là mais quand
je vous dis immense et votre immense et
il fallait en fait chéri d'abord sur ses
tentacules et ses terres et ses chances
et vents violents alors apparemment j'ai
passé un niveau des masses complètement
attardé en plus c'est waou voyez il vend
beaucoup de choses les bosses mais on va
tous amassé kim et marek belka
heureusement qu'on perd 13 cantons
non non non non non non et non
voilà alors c'est vrai que ça on avait
déjà annoncé avec ça c'est un peu
bizarre on dirait que les choses se
rechargent un peu pourquoi rien n'a rien
enfin bon alors on va ramasser tout ce
beau bulletin quoi on peut changer dans
ma classe oui je sais je sais alors data
news est alors est ce qu'ils en sont en
deuil
c'est moche frissons veille exact eh ben
je te suis il allait bien entre claptrap
pas bon allez ramène toi aussi tu
voulais c'est vraiment un boulet à vous
allez voir d'ailleurs si vous voulez un
petit enfin une sorte de hbo va dire à
les tripler sur borderlands n'hésitez
pas à poster un commentaire si ça vous
intéresse ce type de jeu sachant qu'on
peut faire mais comme je trouverai bien
d'autres youtuber avoir bien acheter sur
pc avec lequel fait en coop
il ya aussi torchlight 2 qui va sortir
que j'ai précommandé qu'il coûte que 10
9 euros
vraiment bon c'est pas cher c'est un peu
presque l'équivalent d'un jeu xbox
arcade va pas se mentir
mais en fait c'est une c'est même ce que
j aime l'eau 3 si vous voulez vous voyez
donc la ville d'en haut et ses
équipements radio et il faut en fait
défoncer que tu des ennemis comme dans
diablo
sauf que ça a l'air un peu moins
répétitives bon même si graphiquement
c'est un peu moins splendide 1 il faut
l'avouer c'est bon en même temps 10 9
euros ils n'ont pas les moyens que
blizzard a eu grâce aux fonds qu'ils ont
récoltés grâce à diablo grâce à habas
diablo 2 wii est beau et ses faubourgs
et starcraft aussi notamment
enfin bon voilà donc n'hésitez pas à
demander si vous venez à l'aide sur ce
jeu
et puis bah on vient on fera bientôt une
vidéo sur torchlight 2 qui sortira
demain soir j'offre aussi découvrir ce
jeu et puis un petit pot de pièces pour
ce week-end sur le jeu le plus pourri du
monde voilà tout
alors on va parler à claptrap très bien
dans ce n'est pas la peine de lire je
sais ce qui va se passer je me dis alors
là ça va plus vite on va rejoindre en
fait un bond se doit ami à lui qui n'a
pas trop l'air de l'apprécier vous allez
comprendre pourquoi je dis ça c'est
vraiment pas 3 ou 10 dont les choses un
bon sinon je devrais toi allez hop c'est
parti on sent la somme chao je te suis
classement tu me suis plutôt allez vous
pouvez vous faire des soldes chez
ensemble modulaire c'est ça que j'adore
en bande annonce c'est là que ça aurait
raté je me serais sentie aussi con qu'un
habit un arbitre cus moeurs enfin alors
la base de spécialités de ce personnage
c'est qu'il est un bon jeu commence à
s'en suit chaque aile mais des espèces
de coups de roubaix fait mal dit non tu
as quoi qu'il se passe qu'est ce qui se
passe je ne comprends pas et toi
mais jolie elle fait plutôt mal en fait
la sienne alors je vais vous montrer
aussi quelque chose bon là on voit les
équipements que j'ai etc lie à la map
ici vous voyez donc l'arbre de talents
donc ça se débloquera en fait je crois
niveau 5 ou 6 donc ça c'est le sort
principal de la sirène et puis ensuite
il y a trois arbres de talents dont
carla disposition classique d'un arbre
de talents qu'il ya un peu dont tout il
y aura d'antan qui dans torchlight 2 je
sais qu'il ya ça dans gow 2 enfin dans
beaucoup de mmo c'est un peu une triple
un triple arbres enfin triple
spécialisation dans league of legends
aussi il me semble que c'est une tribu
espère pas dire de bêtises
et puis donc chacun sa spécialité bon
par exemple je sais qu'avec l'assassin
il y en a une c'est plus pour jouer que
les armes une peluche le sniper zut je
veux corps à corps donc c'est assez
intéressant mais encore une fois on
retrouve l'aspect rpg ce plutôt cool
vraiment intéressant donc bon on pourra
exploiter ça un petit peu plus tard
quand on sera dans le bel20 25
réellement même même plus encore parce
que là j'avoue qu'il ya pas grand chose
à faire
au pied des troupes j'espère que d'ici
là par asus a mais le bug
voilà on va tenter le nôtre qu'officier
gens sont mais je vais les
applaudissements fondation
et alors ne pas vouloir sortir de son
truc olé la lnd à damas
nos scores qu'est-ce qui la rendent bien
ça fait bizarre d'ailleurs j'ai
littéralement pulvérisé le geek agir
batf micro la dernière fois j'ai fait du
passé jean et vous en une semaine dont
j'avoue y avait michael double xp qui a
quand même un peu et de marais comment
ils courent en plus tôt juste derrière
mon dieu vraiment un jeu très très
prenant ce bordel je suis heureux qu'ils
sortent enfin pour moi c'était le jeu
que j'attendais cette année avec 10
alors que j'ai pas mis dans le top 15
des roums avaient lynché littéralement
pour ça vous avez n'était pas content
apparemment je sais j'aurais dû le met
malheureusement je pouvais pas mettre
tous les jeux qui sortiront cette année
non plus et j'avoue que j'aurais pu par
exemple ou encore d'un fort est une
énorme sortie mais j'avoue que j'aurais
peut-être pu mettre à la place quand
même dit aussi ce laptop est ce qui va
sortir exclu ps3 qui a l'air tout
simplement énorme
enfin beaucoup je énormément de l'équipe
et donc vont vous attendre sur youtube
avec vos tubes préférés enfin votre
police pas qui c'est mais en tout cas si
c'est fait plus vous allez être servis
on va tous bombarder les let's play et
les vidéos sur plein de vieux bar au
marché c'est bien ça va un petit peu
varié cette année call of duty qu'on a
eu lie à séquencer les dernières fois où
c'était vraiment ou youtube heure était
à fond sur color ça va changer un peu ce
qu'on peut vraiment aux lettres aura
magnifique
vraiment on va être certes bienvenue
mais la diversité c'est à dire sur
youtube grâce à tous les gens qui vont
sortir vient on sera tous contents ça
pas de soucis rencontrés sur ma mère
dont il se trouve et ses comptes dans
cette phase on and on parle alors je
veux se tromper pour moi ah oui c'est
vrai
alors il veut que lui en avant oh oui
c'est vrai on sait si avant voit aussi
des dons de faire ce qu'a fait des
piques
je sais qu'en bas de son dos au but un
[ __ ] [ __ ] danger lundi ce qui nous
est ce qu'il doit à 4 ce qu'ils ont
excusez moi vois pas de soucis armées lu
en classe et lui fera du bien
il a l'air un peu amoché on va se mentir
il flanche le pôle 1ère on peut encore
observer le paysage au est plus un petit
peu plus de bleus là bas regardez
comment ils voyaient ce qui se passe
elle est trop blasé par exemple
il s'élance trautmann c'est juste et là
je suis juste là n'est qu'un jeu peut
rétablir l'alimentation principale de ce
lieu propose bien des choses qui peuvent
être utiles contre
voilà donc là effectivement faudrait que
j'utilise les voyages et la retenue tout
faire à pied
enfin bon c'est j'espère que cette
petite vidéo découverte vous aura plu ça
fait déjà à peu près 20 minutes qu'on
devrait être en vidéo on se retrouvera
bientôt si vous voulez bottes si vous
voulez laisser en commentaire si vous
voulez un petit let's play sur
borderlands ou plus de vidéos sur
borderlands ou quoi je continuerai ce
père cela donc la sirène ou alors ou
alors vous savez quoi il y aura un
sondage dans la description avec les 4
persos disponible donc vous cliquez sur
celui que vous préférez voir dans ce
bled plaît en tout cas j'espère que je
vous plais car il est tout simplement
énormissime je vous conseille vraiment
de le prendre et de vous faire vraiment
des gros kiff entre amis en tout cas le
solo est super long et à de nombreux dlc
qui sont ils vont sortir en plus c'est
un espèce de borderlands premier on va
dire en quelque sorte on paie que 30
euros et on aura les cas dlc prévus
entre maintenant et juin 2013
en tout cas j'espère que ça vous plaira
et moi je vous dis à bientôt